So for our next version, let's parallelize this per element, right?
So we essentially replaced the inner loop with a thread launch.
Let's replace the outer and inner loops with a thread launch.
And I'm going to leave this as a programming exercise for you to do.
We'll give you the same code that we've been using here
with a little bit more instrumentation that should be pretty obvious.
Go ahead and run this code, verify the timings.
They might be different on whatever GPU and system you're running on.
And then add a new kernel,
which performs the transpose on a per element basis and see how it times out.
Now one thing to be aware of when you're doing this programming exercise
is that you can only launch up to a 1,024 threads in a thread block,
so I suggest you organize your code to use K by K thread blocks,
multiple thread blocks, each of dimension of K by K,
and use a value of, like, 16 for K for now.
We're going to play around with this value a little bit later.